in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for June 1st, on which we commemorate our righteous
Father Justin of Celizia.
Our Holy Father Justin, abbot of Celizia monastery in Valgevo, Western Serbia, was born to
Pius and God-fearing parents, Brota Spiridon, and Protinika Anastasia Popovic, in Vranje,
South Serbia, on the feast of the Annunciation, March 25th, 1894.
Brota means priest, and Protinika means Presbytera.
He was born into a priestly family, as seven previous generations of the Popovic's were
headed by priests.
Popovic in Serbian actually means family, or Son, of a priest.
At baptism, he was given the name Blagoge, after the feast of the Annunciation.
Blagovest means Annunciation, or good news.
Being raised in a pious Christian atmosphere, young Blagoge learned quite early of the
virtuous life in Christ, as dedicated in service to God's Holy Church.
As a child, he often visited with his parents the Prohor Pciński monastery, dedicated to
Saint Prohor, the miracle worker.
He witnessed firsthand the miraculous power of the Lord manifested through Saint Prohor,
as his mother, Anastasia, was healed of a deadly disease by the saint's intercessions,
and Blagoge was still a young boy.
Blagoge was an excellent student in elementary school.
His greatest love was for the Bible, and the four gospels, in particular.
He began serious reading of the Bible at age 14, and throughout the rest of his life he carried
the New Testament on his person, reading faithfully three chapters a day.
In 1905, after finishing the fourth grade in Wranje, following the tradition of the Popovic
family, young Blagoge entered the nine-year program of secular and religious study at the
seminary and faculty of Saint Sava in Belgrade.
In the early twentieth century, the School of Saint Sava in Belgrade was renowned throughout
the Orthodox world, as a holy place of extremist cynicism, as well as of a high-quality scholarship.
Some of the well-known professors were the Rector, Father Domentian, Professor Father
Dosythios, Later Abyssal, and Athanasios Popovic, and the great ecclesial composer, Stephen
Mokranje, yet one professor stood ahead in shoulders above the rest, the then Hyromunk
Nikolai Velomitevich, Ph.D., Father Nikolai, the single most influential person in his life.
From the venerable Nikolai, Blagoge learned of the virtuous ascetic life in Christ, the Lord,
the doctrinal genius of the great fathers of the Church, and of the spiritual and intellectual
effort needed to probe the important philosophical and theological questions of the day.
In the end, both of these two spiritual geniuses possessed a commitment to Christ the Lord,
which provided them with a truly Orthodox vision of life, which in turn made them the
two greatest voices of the Serbian Orthodox Church in modern times.
Both Nikolai and Blagoge, later monk Justin, sought to speak the truth in love to a passing
world.
They sought the answers to the world's most pressing problems in the teachings of the Scriptures
and the fathers of the Church, and especially in the experiences found in the lives of the
saints.
The saints were for them living Bibles, incarnate dogmas, and the true source of Orthodox theology,
experiential knowledge of God, and existential pedagogical truth valid for all times.
In 1914, at the age of 20, Blagoge had finished the nine-year program of Saint Savas in Belgrade.
At this time, he had only one desire in mind that I may dwell in the house of the Lord
all the days of my life, that I may behold the delight of the Lord, and that I may visit
his holy temple.
With this hunger and thirst for righteousness driving him, Blagoge wanted to radically
devote his life to Christ in the monastic vocation.
However, due to the beginning of World War I in 1914 and the declining health of his parents,
Blagoge decided to postpone his entrance into the monastic ranks.
During the early part of World War I, autumn of 1914, Blagoge served as a student nurse,
primarily in South Serbia, Skadar, Nis, Kosovo, etc.
Unfortunately, while in this capacity he contracted typhus during the winter of 1914 and had
to spend over a month in a hospital in Nis.
On January 8th of 1915, he resumed his duties.
It suits to say that Blagoge and the rest of the aides and nurses, as well as all of the
freedom-loving Serbian Christians in South Serbia, suffered bitterly from the effects of the
war.
On the eve of the feast of St. Nicholas, his Sna Slava, family patron saint, 1915, Blagoge
returned to Skadar in order to visit metropolitan Dmitrius, who later became the first patriarch
after the patriarchal throne was renewed in 1920.
Blagoge received the monastic tuncher in the church in Skadar, taking the name Justin, after
the great Christian philosopher and martyr for Christ, St. Justin, the philosopher.
This name was truly a gift and sign from heaven, for it was as a philosopher and seeker of Christian
truth that the humble monk Justin would later receive glory from God.
Shortly after becoming a monk, Justin, along with several other students who received
the Metropolitan's blessing, traveled to Petrograd, Russia, to begin a year's study
in the orthodox seminary there.
It was there the young monk Justin first dedicated himself more fully to orthodoxy and the
monastic way.
He learned of the great ascetics of Russia, Anthony and Fildosius of the Caves in Kiev, Seraphim
of Satov, Sergeus of Radhanes, John of Constant and others.
Justin fell in love with Russian spirituality and piety, especially that exhibited by the
common folk of the countryside.
After his year's study and sojourn in Russia, Justin entered by the prompting of his spiritual
father Nikolai, the theological school in Oxford, England.
He spent seven semesters at Oxford, November 1916 to May 1919, yet he did not receive a diploma
since his doctoral dissertation entitled The Philosophy and Religion of Dostoevsky was
not accepted.
As a result, Justin returned to Belgrade after the war and became a teacher in the seminary
at Katerovak Strem.
At Sremsky Katerovak, Justin renewed the ancient study of the lives of the saints, as being
a proper theological focus and most important course of study.
It was at this time that he received the calling and vision from God to translate into modern
servient the entire lives of the saints of the orthodox church, a feat which to this day
is truly astounding.
In September of 1919, Justin entered the Greek Orthodox School of Theology in Athens, Greece.
He spent two years there to finish his doctoral coursework.
Just as in Russia, monk Justin traveled throughout the countryside of Greece, especially benefiting
spiritually from the Greek Orthodox heritage commonly known as the Byzantine legacy.
In 1920, venerable Justin was ordained deacon and began to experience another side of the
church's liturgical life, leadership of the worship services.
As his liturgical and ascetical life increased, Justin matured spiritually and became known
throughout all of Greece as a most pious ascetic.
At this time, due to his unceasing prayer to the most sweet Jesus, Justin was granted by
the grace of the Holy Spirit, the gift of Umilenezhik coupled with tears.
In May of 1921, deacon Justin returned to Sremsky-Karovak and resumed his teaching duties
at the seminary.
He taught on the New Testament, dogmatics, patristics, and the lives of the saints.
Prior to each lesson of the scriptures, he opened with his short prayer.
Almost sweet Lord, by the power of thy Holy Gospel, and through thy apostles teach me and
announce through me what I am to say.
One year later, on the feast of the beheading of John the Baptist, in 1922, venerable Justin
was ordained priest by his holiness, Patriarch Dmitrizh.
Throughout the ordination service, Justin was in tears, crying as a newborn babe in the
Lord.
His humility attracted many, as his disciples grew rapidly in number.
Not only students, but also many lay people, came to him for confession, counsel, and spiritual
healing.
His most beloved disciples were those pious men and women of the Bogomodjak-Bokret, the
Serbian prayer movement, originally formed and led by the newly consecrated Bishop Nikolai.
The great Bishop Nikolai, as the great apostle of the 20th century, as the new chrysystem
of all times.
These two were as Anthony and Athanasius, and Basil and Gregory of Old, two bodies yet
one mind.
As their love for our Lord Jesus Christ produced much spiritual fruit in the lives of many
zealots.
Everyone especially enjoyed singing the spiritual songs written by Bishop Nikolai.
These ones, written in the vernacular language of the people, were not only quite spiritual
and edifying, but also were didactic and doctrinal in nature.
And it was this praising the Lord in the people's language which inspired Justin to translate
into modern Serbian, from the original Greek text, the Divine Liturgy of St. John chrysystem.
Following the scriptural and liturgical tradition of the church, given to the Slavs by the great
evangelical missionaries Cyril and Methodius and their disciples, that is the tradition
of hearing the word of God and praying in the mother tongues of the people.
Both Justin and Nikolai were able by the energy of the Holy Spirit to edify and lighten
and confirm in orthodoxy the pious faithful in their own tongue.
The zealous Father Justin was also in close contact at this time with two great Russian
orthodox pastors, Metropolitan Anthony Grapovitski, who taught at the seminary in Sremski
Karlova and the exiled Russian bishop John Max Simovic.
Holy Father John, a man of extreme asceticism, was truly a miracle worker, and is coming
later to America where he reposed in the Lord in San Francisco, became a blessing and visitation
from the Lord for those God-seekers there.
In 1923, Father Justin became the editor of the orthodox journal Christian Life, and in
this journal appeared his first doctoral dissertation, the philosophy and religion of Dostoevsky,
for which he was persecuted at Oxford.
Three years later, in 1926, his second doctoral dissertation, the problem of person and knowledge
in St. Macadios of Egypt, was published in Greek in Athens.
Father Justin was now on his way to establishing himself as a modern father of the church.
For his course on the lives of the saints, Justin began to translate into Serbia in the lives
of the saints from the Greek, Syriac and Slavonic sources, as well as numerous minor
works of the fathers, homilies of John Chrysostom, Macadios and Isaac the Syrian.
He also wrote an exquisite book, The Theory of Knowledge, according to St. Isaac.
Justin's blossoming literary genius amazed everyone.
In 1931, after a stint as professor in the Theological Academy in Prisren, the brilliant
father Justin was requested by the Holy Synod in Belgrade to assist Bishop Joseph Svićovich
of Bitala and reorganizing the Church of the Carpatho-Russians in Czechoslovakia.
This area had been besieged by those espousing unionism.
Justin, an established defender of the faith, was a great aid to the reorganization of the
Orthodox Church of Czechoslovakia.
This experience made him realize a tremendous need of the Serbs to have in their mother tongue
an exact and complete exposition of the Orthodox faith.
As a result, he began writing after his return to Bitala in 1932, his monumental work, The
Dogmas of the Orthodox Church, in three volumes.
Volume one published in the late 1932 dealt with the sources and method of theology, the nature
of God and the teaching on the Holy Trinity, creation and divine providence.
This volume was so well received that Dr. Justin was chosen in 1934 as professor of dogmatics
at the theological faculty of St. Sava in Belgrade.
One year later, this hardworking writer completed the second volume entitled The God-Man and
his work, Christology and Soteriology.
There is no doubt that these two volumes on the third and final volume, ecclesiology,
teaching on the Church, published later in 1970, are the most complete with his most
ascetical vision of life, produced for all Christians, a magnificent analysis of the ancient
faith of the Church.
In 1938, Father Justin, along with a number of noted intellectuals of Belgrade, founded the
Serbian Philosophical Society.
Holy Father Justin began at this time to probe the philosophical and world issues of his day.
His penetrating mind was fully displayed in two books.
The Foundations of Theology, 1939, and Dostoevsky on Europe and Slavism, 1940.
Both of these works dealt with the nature and method of theology and the spirit and vision
of Western civilization.
Father Justin was never fearful of telling the truth concerning the fallen state of humankind,
particularly the follies of Western European religious and secular life.
Father Justin remained in the capacity of professor of dogmatics in Belgrade until the end of World
War II.
Within the perspective of the newly established communist and atheistic regime, the likes
of Azele's Christians such as Father Justin, who was now beginning to convert the intellectuals
to faith in Jesus Christ, had no place.
He alone with several other teachers was ousted from the university system in Belgrade
and told never to return.
Thus ended the university teaching career in Belgrade of the great Reverend Dr. Justin Popovic.
For two years after his exile from Belgrade, the ascetic Justin lived in several monasteries
in Serbia, Kalenik, Ovkar, Sukovov and Ravanitsa.
And on May 14, 1948, he entered Salija Monastery near the village of Lelik, only a few miles
from the major town of Valjevo, Western Serbia.
Father Justin remained in Salija Monastery until his repose in the Lord on March 25, 1979.
He became our commander right there and was the spiritual head of the monastery.
Under his guidance, Salija Monastery became a convent.
A school of iconography renewing the Serbo Byzantine style was also begun there, and a new chapel
dedicated to St. John Chrysostom as well as residential quarters were constructed in 1970.
Many pious people from all parts of Yugoslavia, Greece, the Balkans and literally all parts
of the world came to hear him preach and teach the correct faith and life in Christ by the
energy of the Holy Spirit.
Without a doubt, from the end of World War I until his repose in the Lord, Archimandra
Justin was the pillar of Orthodoxy in his homeland.
During the time of confinement in Salija Monastery, he accomplished an amazing literary feat.
He translated and compiled from various sources twelve volumes, one per month, of the lives
of the saints.
Father Justin, communed of the Holy Gives daily.
For the Eucharist, the precious body and blood of our Lord Jesus Christ, was his daily bread
and the true source of his entire life, work, teaching and existence.
His words, deed and thoughts exuded a lifestyle reminiscent of the ancient fathers of the church.
Another father of the church walked this earth in the person of St. Justin.
In addition to the lives of the saints, he produced many other writings in Salija, some
of which are still unpublished, displaying a highly analytical and perceptive mind and
heart.
He actually created a new theological and philosophical language necessary to reach the heart
of the modern human being, and his writings and teachings reflect a genuine and total commitment
to the Lord Jesus Christ.
A commitment characterized by extreme asceticism, as well as by the contemplative vision of
the divine light of God, the Holy Trinity.
He was living dogma and a flute of the spirit, reflecting the divine love of God, the Holy Trinity,
theology was life to St. Justin.
St. Justin fell asleep in the Lord on March 25, 1979, on his birthday, the feast of the
annunciation.
He was 85 years of age.
After his most honorable burial, which was attended by hundreds of pious believers, who came
from many parts of the world, he was laid to rest facing east, behind the main church
of Salija monastery.
To this day, Eulogies praising his virtue and love of Christ continue to be heard from
all parts of the Orthodox world.
Also miracles have occurred at his gravesite, such as healings, flashes of brilliant and
divine light from his tomb, as well as many conversions of unbelievers who have either
read his writings, or have been personally visited by Almighty God through the prayers of
St. Justin.
Truly, St. Justin's legacy is a great one.
Many disciples are now extolling his name and imitating his life by drinking from the inexhaustible
riches of grace and truth, which he revealed to us.
O Holy Father Justin, thy sweetness of life refreshes our souls.
Thy love for truth and desire to live with all the saints is a reminder to us of our own
calling from God to pursue virtue, that we, most unenlightened and miserable sinners, may
open our hearts to the knowledge of truth incarnate, the Lord Jesus Christ, to whom belongs
glory, honor and worship, together with his unoriginate Father, and life-giving Spirit,
now and ever and unto the ages of ages, amen.
To the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, of mercy on us and
save us.